all right I've saved the best for last
here is the best definition okay
and I'm going to go full circle okay I'm
gonna I went from words to kind of
algebra stuff technical stuff I'm gonna
go back to words I think the best
definition and I'll try and justify best
in a second
the best definition for absolute value
is the distance from I'm gonna be a
little more specific from the origin so
the absolute value of a is how far is a
from the origin okay so for this I need
a picture
okay so draw the picture with me you've
got your number line there for values of
X now think with me what is the best way
to label this to demonstrate this
principle okay I'm going to go back to
the numbers I picked at the beginning
okay where is the distance
well it's alike it's this length here if
I was thinking of five my first example
so when I put this distance here oh
maybe I should put a lip there I can
only use this distance is absolute value
five which happens to be forehead right
because if it's cleaner that's the
that's how long I would have to travel
to get back if I wanted this distance
here because the origin is here and
maybe three is here what's that
dispenser and yesterday but the answer
is is three units so the absolute value
of 3 is 3 that's the distance I have to
travel to get back to the origin okay
now for definitions you will need all of
them at different points okay which is
why I'm giving you all of them the last
one and this is why I say it's the best
one okay the last one generalizes best
it goes to it's the definition that fits
the broadest range of situations okay it
might seem a bit silly like why would
you bother saying you know talking our
distance at all when you can appeal such
a simple way of thinking about okay and
the answer is spoilers for the next
course you might enroll in distance from
the origin is a trivial problem if all
you have is one dimension because
distance from 5 is just 5 that distance
from 100 is just 100 all you have to do
is just say what the distance is aha
but not all numbers have one dimension
if for instance
I had another direction to go in another
dimension that I could move in suppose
there was a number that wasn't along
here suppose there was a number over
here okay just for the sake of it just
for the lawls I'm just gonna call it Z
okay this has a definition the absolute
value of Z has a definition under this
scheme that it doesn't really have under
any of these right in this where is the
absolute value of Z it's the distance to
the origin right that there is the
absolute value said now tell me I'm in
two dimensions here right how will that
work out this distance I would make a
right angle triangle you can make it
anywhere I like say say there's a right
angle triangle if I knew what this was
and I knew what this was and the
absolute value of this number whatever
it is would be the square root of that
square sorry
yeah that's great Plus that because
that's what Pythagoras tells us okay so
when if / when we get to that right this
is the same idea absolute value because
as you can see it's time to going
through some pretty different territory
when you look at this it actually gets
given a different name which you'll
learn later probably okay but it's still
the same idea it's still the same
notation you will see these two bars
appearing you'll be like on on this
seems familiar it still means the same
thing so this is the definition I like
best but you need all of them